what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we are going to be
talking about the zone fruits and their
powers this video is long overdue since
I said I'd make it when the logia video
hit over a thousand likes and it's
already over four thousand five hundred
plenty of you commented that you're
still waiting for the follow up to that
first video so here it is finally thank
you for your patience if you want to see
more one piece videos on this channel
let me know by smashing that like button
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is really important
hit that notification bell so you
actually get notified when new videos
come out there will be manga spoilers in
this video obviously since I'll be
covering all known zone users and
without further ado let's jump into it
first let's look at the first zone to be
properly introduced in the series
Dalton is the king of the Sakura kingdom
and the possessor of mushi oshino me
model bison aka the ox ox fruit bison
model quick notes on the english names
i'll just be using the Funimation
translation for the most part rather
than listing all of the different
translations which would take too long
just keep in mind there are different
translations used in the manga and in
the old for kids version of one piece
but i want to keep things simple for the
purposes of this video anyways with this
fruit dalton gains two extra forms as
most zone users do for him it's the
bison human hybrid form in the full
bison form using the ox Hawks food
powers Dalton is shown to be fast enough
to dodge bullets and strong enough to
take down multiple soldiers at the same
time next we have our favorite blue
Nosed Reindeer dr. Tony Tony chopper the
possessor of the keto hito no me aka the
human human fruit in addition to gaining
extra forms from the human human fruit
chopper also gained human intelligence
which lets him think like a human speak
like a human and learn like a human it
pretty much lets him do anything a human
can do except you know swim chopper can
take the form of a regular reindeer aka
walk point a human reindeer hybrid aka
brain point and a human that looks like
the abominable snowman with a blue nose
aka
Hevy point his human ask chibi form or
brain point form is the form he takes
most at a time after a time skip he can
use additional forms without the help of
a rumble ball like jumping point guard
point arm point horn point and kung-fu
point chopper still needs the rumble
ball to enter monster point his
strongest form but after the time skip
he can control himself and communicate
in this monstrously powerful form there
is so much more detail we could go into
but here we're going broad rather than
deep since we're covering so many
characters so we have to keep moving but
you can let me know in the comments if
you really want to see a dedicated video
on a specific zone user next we have pel
the Falcon a head guard in alabasta and
the strongest warrior alabasta has to
offer
he'll eat the tori tori no me model
Falcon devil fruit a key the bird bird
fruit model to Falcon one of the only
five flying devil fruits known to exist
he has his human form a hybrid Falcon
human form and a full Falcon form that
he used to take maybe flying in the past
in addition to letting him fly his
Falcon form is also strong enough to
carry a giant bomb away from the city
not surprisingly the fruit gives him
incredible speed he's been known to soar
through the air at breakneck speeds
while firing machine guns at enemies but
he can take them out quickly with his
talents as well next we have town
collapse er dro fee aka mist Merry
Christmas she is a former agent of
baroque works who worked as mr. force
partner she ate the Mogu muginami aka
the mole mole fruit the fruit lets her
completely turned into a mole or a mole
person hybrid the really cool thing
about this power is that it lets the
user move through the underground as
freely as if they were swimming through
water miss Merry Christmas can use her
giant mole claws to even break through
stone walls next we have lasso who
serves as mr. force gun somehow the gun
gained the powers of the Annina no me
dachshund aka the dog dog fruit model
dachshund the main advantage here is
that the in
gun can now move of its own accord
firing exploding baseballs at the enemy
and just when you thought it couldn't
get any weirder the gun because it's
gained dog abilities can now get sick
and catch a cold if the gun dog sneezes
it will accidentally fire off shots at
random next up we have chocolate the
jackal another head guard in alabasta he
ate the ena in uno me model jackal aka
the dog dog fruit model you guessed it
jackal he gained the ability to
transform into a full jackal form and a
jackal human hybrid form when he ate the
fruit he fights primarily with a sword
but his devil fruit powers increases
speed attack power and senses so he can
use his weapon even more effectively
then we have Pierre gun falls bird
Pierre a de uma uma Noemi a key the
horse horse fruit and gained the ability
to transform into a winged horse kind of
like a less majestic Pegasus like a lot
less majestic God fall uses Pierre's
Pegasus form to ride on top of him while
Pierre uses his horse teeth to bite
people who disrespect his owner now this
is some hashtag epic teamwork after the
bird horse we have a sword elephant
called funk freed funk freed is former
chief of cp9 spanned UM's sword who
somehow gained the powers of the Zozo no
me aka the elephant elephant fruit this
sword can use this power to transform
into a full elephant or into an elephant
sword hybrid in the latter case its
trunk is replaced with a sword that can
potentially charge in two enemies
because of the fruit the sword gained
elephant strength and intelligence which
can be useful because it allows a sword
to follow its owner's orders however now
that the sword has intelligence it also
fears death which is how Frankie can
threaten it into obeying him next we
have Rob Lucci the strongest member of
what used to be cp9 he ate the neckline
economy model leopard aka the cat cat
fruit model leopard he can turn into a
full leopard or a human leopard hybrid
since he ate a carnivorous zone type
fruit he is more ferocious than most and
excels in physical strength and close
combat
he combines his powers like his super
strength speed and claws with the
superhuman martial arts style roku
shichi making him a truly formidable not
to mention cool opponent following the
leopard man of cp9 we have the wolf man
of cp9 jabra 8 the Eno in anomie model
wolf aka the dog dog fruit model wolf
he's pretty much a werewolf
he usually fights in his Wolf Man hybrid
form in a lot of ways his powers are
like Lucchese just replace a carnivorous
leopard with a carnivorous wolf Jabra is
not as strong as Lucci but similar power
boosts apply and he even uses roku
shichi as well now cute a giraffe man
Kaku another former cp9 member 800 she
she know me model giraffe aka the Ox
Hawks fruit model giraffe it's not quite
as cool as a leopard or wolf but cop who
can transform into a full giraffe or a
human giraffe hybrid in his hybrid form
he still has a huge neck and a blocky
appearance along with increased strength
Kaku finds ways to use his long giraffe
neck to his advantage it increases his
reach additionally he can pull his neck
into his body and suddenly extend it in
the direction of his opponent like a
cannon he's also used swords in
conjunction with his giraffe powers
he's definitely skilled as far as
giraffe swordsmen go probably like top
three but not skilled enough to take out
our boys Oro next we have the younger
sister of boa hancock boa sander sonia
she was forced to eat the heavy heavy
Noemi model anaconda aka the snake snake
fruit model anaconda when she was still
a slave of the celestial dragons the
devil fruit gives her the ability to
turn into a giant get this anaconda
along with super strength she has
impressive reach and versatility when
using her snake powers due to her large
long snake-like body she can grab people
with her tail stab them or even turn her
hair into additional moving snake heads
whose fangs are as strong as iron sander
Sonia's younger sister boa marigold has
a very similar story she was forced to
eat the heavy heavy Noemi model King
Cobra aka the snake snake fruit
old king cobra in physical appearance
marigold and sander Sonia are pretty
much opposites
while sander Sonia has a big head and
thin body marigold has a smaller head in
a much bigger body nevertheless their
snake-like powers are pretty much the
same marigold also turns into a giant
snake and can turn her hair into
additional snake heads next up we have
minnow Taurus minnow rhinoceros minnow
koala and minnows zebra these four are
jailor beasts that impel down there
awakens own users but we do not know the
name of their specific devil fruits
because they are awakened devil fruit
users they have further increased
strength speed durability and recovery
however they no longer seem to be
capable of complex thought they are more
similar to animals than humans in the
sense but like humans they do continue
to walk on two feet despite the fact
that we don't know the exact names of
their fruits we can deduce what their
specific animal powers are from their
appearances and names mineral tourists
like the fictional Minotaur seems to
have the powers of a bull mineral
rhinoceros has the powers of a rhino
minnow koala has the powers of a koala
and you know zebra has the powers of a
zebra although they appear to be closer
to monstrous animals than humans at this
point they do sometimes use weapons for
instance me know Taurus uses a club when
he first fights against Luffy for the
cover of chapter 662 we also get a look
at a new cute but deadly jailer beast
called me know Chihuahua as you may have
guessed he has the powers of a chihuahua
never underestimate zone fruits though
since even the seemingly weakest animals
can make for insanely powerful zone
users and me know Chihuahua definitely
wouldn't be a jailer beast if he wasn't
extremely strong next up we have Vice
Admiral onigumo he was one of the five
vice Admirals to lead the buzzer call
against Annie's Lobby
his devil fruit name is unknown but he
seems to be a Spider Man of sorts
probably not as funny as that other
Spider Man but he can grow three pairs
of black spider like arms so compared to
Zorro who wields three swords
onigumo can wield eight at a time or use
his arms
detained his enemy instead after
vice-admiral spider-man we have Vice
Admiral Dalmatian man
Vice Admiral Dalmatian ate an unnamed
devil fruit and gained the powers of a
Dalmatian although we don't know the
name of his devil fruit I guess it's
called the dog dog fruit model Dalmatian
but who knows maybe it's just a
Dalmatian who ate the human human fruit
model Vice Admiral but whatever anyways
he uses his powers in conjunction with
roku shichi style and he's definitely
not afraid to use it against our favored
rubber boy Luffy next we have a ploy de
let's just hope that's how it said a new
world pirate was allied with white beard
as you can tell by his ship in pirate
flag employ de is associated with the
caterpillar his unnamed devil fruit lets
him enter a caterpillar like form which
can aid him in battle
you wouldn't necessarily think that
caterpillars are powerful but employed
ax is respected as a fearsome and
infamous new world pirate next we have
Peckham's who works as a combatant for
pirate Emperor or if you prefer Yong ko
big mom Peckham's is a lion mink and if
you need a refresher minks are
human-like beings sort of like fish men
who take on the characteristics of a
specific animal in addition to being a
lion mink pet comes aid the comic
commando me aka the turtle turtle fruit
with disability pekoms can create a
protective shell that is as hard as
diamond
pekoms has even used a shell to protect
himself from bullets following that
human lion turtle creature we got smiley
the slime
Cesar clowns pet smiley is a blob of
condensed gas which gained the power of
the sight asada no meat model axolotl
aka the saw saw a fruit axolotl model
the fruit gives intelligence to the
slime allowing the giant muck like
creature to chase down its enemies in
horror movie fashion since it's a slime
it can separate into smaller slimes and
then come back together into one big
giant slime eventually smiley lost the
power becoming unintelligent deadly gas
again and a nearby Apple became the new
sana sana Noemi model axolotl devil
fruit now let's turn to 2 dwarfs from
the ton Tata Kingdom Kabu a cake
is the leader of the yellow Cub squad
and a member of the tan Tata pirates
he ate the Musha Musha no me model
Kabuto Mishi aka bug bug fruit model
rhinoceros beetle when he uses the devil
fruit powers Kabu can grow extra arms
wings and a horn with wings Kabu can fly
at quick speeds and he is strong enough
to send humans flying with a head but
then there's a leader of the pink B
squad and fellow tone Tata pirate beyond
beyond eight the moshi-moshi no me model
Suzumiya chi aka the bagua fruit model
hornet similarly to cub beyond gains an
extra pair of arms and the ability to
fly
however since she gains hornet powers
she gets a stinger instead of a horn now
we finally arrived to the greatest tea
pot in all of the multiverses boom buku
this tea pot belongs to swordsmith Tengu
Yama heated soup bong Goku the tea set
gained the powers of the enol in anomie
model tanuki a tanuki is a Japanese
raccoon dog as with other inanimate
objects gaining devil food powers means
they gain a degree of intelligence
perhaps et cetra kun hybrid is not super
useful in battle but if tea set thieves
ever show up boon buku can always turn
into a full tanuki and expertly avoid
capture and that's it for regular zone
users but we still have ancient zone
users and that's right mythical zone
users to cover since I do want to make
detailed future videos about both
ancient and mythical zone users I'll try
to keep it pretty simple here starting
off with ancient zones we have ex trake
the man who used to be a Marine rear
admiral but turned pirate and became the
captain of the Drake pirates
he ate the you do you know me model
Allosaurus aka the dragon dragon fruit
Allosaurus model as a result Drake has
carnivorous dinosaur powers he is
currently a high-ranking member of the
beasts pirates page one is another
high-ranking member of the beasts
pirates ta da doo doo no me model
spinosaurus and gain the power to turn
into one of the largest of all known
carnivore
dinosaurs the Spinosaurus is
specifically known for its distinctive
spine both page 1 and X Drake are two of
the strongest headliners a high-ranked
within the beast pirates because they're
so strong they were both promoted to
being one of the flying six headliners
they are outranked by both Kaido and the
all-stars among the all-stars there are
the three disasters otherwise known as
kaido's right hand men they're
considered to be the highest-ranking
members of the beasts pirates after
keidel first there's Jack the drought
who ate the Zozo know me model mammoth
and gain the powers of a giant mammoth
second there's King the conflagration
weight of you to know me model
Pteranodon and gain the powers of a
giant pterodactyl like creature
Pteranodon were actually some of the
largest known flying reptiles to ever
exist third we have Queen the plague who
ate the you do know me model
Brachiosaurus and gain the powers to
turn into a giant long-necked dinosaur
in his dinosaur form Queen even towers
over big mom now we are getting into the
most hyped up zone devil fruits the
mythical zone fruits let's heat things
up with marco de phoenix white beers
right-hand man he ate the Tori Tori
Noemi model Phoenix aka the bird bird
fruit model Phoenix as we know from
Harry Potter and x-men Phoenix's are
epic and Opie Marco is no exception
because Phoenix's can turn into flames
Marco's own devil fruit can act a lot
like a logia devil fruit the blue flamed
Phoenix has insane regeneration powers
similarly to how it is said that a
Phoenix can rise from its own ashes
otherwise he can fly use his talents to
slash out his enemies selectively
transform only parts of his body like
his arms and just kick butt like a rock
star
next we have sangoku the Buddha before
the time-skip he was the Fleet Admiral
of the Marines which is actually the
highest marine rank sangoku has a very
interesting power
he ate the hito hito no me model
dai-butsu aka the human human fruit
model Buddha the fruit allows him to
transform into a giant and extremely
powerful gold Buddha sangoku can use his
palms to launch shockwaves at his enemy
these shockwaves are powerful enough to
even injure the Blackbeard pirates
following the Fleet Admiral we have the
pirate emperor aku ankka Kaido of the
beasts he is often called the most
powerful creature in the world if that
ain't an epic title to hold I don't know
what is the official name of the fruit
that Kaito ate is not known but in a
Piercy ate a mythical zone fruit more
specifically an Eastern dragon devil
fruit now he can transform to a giant
powerful dragon at will in Chinese
mythology the dragon symbolizes power
strength and good luck so you can bet
he'll be a formidable and epic foe then
we have an infamous female pirate
Katerina Devon aka the crescent moon
hunter she is considered to be the most
dangerous female pirate to have ever
been imprisoned at impel down and now
she's a member of the Blackbeard pirates
Katerina ate the Naruto devil fruit aka
the Anu Anu no me QB no kitsune this
devil fruit lets her transform into the
nine-tailed Fox pokémon has their own
spin on this Japanese folk tale and so
does Naruto so I'm glad one piece
included the nine tails Fox to the nine
tailed fox devil fruit allows Katerina
to transform into other people which has
to be one of the most useful powers in
all of one piece and then we have kudos
Umi Orochi
the current Shogun of Juan oh he ate the
heavy heavy Noemi model Yamata no Orochi
aka the snake snake fruit model eight
headed mythological snake you may
recognize this from Naruto as well
because Orochimaru is a reference to
this snake myth too with this power
Orochi can turn into a giant snake-like
creature with eight heads all of which
can crush most enemies with a single
bite and that is it for every zone fruit
except for artificial zone fruits and
non-canon zone fruits both of which I'll
cover in separate videos if there's
enough interest in this one and let me
just say wow that took a long long time
if you guys want to keep seeing these
videos make sure to hit that like button
and share the video with anyone who
likes one piece because a lot of work
goes into videos like this one and I'll
only do
all paramecia if you guys can show me
that you really really want it thank you
for watching if you enjoyed make sure to
obviously hit that like button as I
mentioned if you haven't be sure to
subscribe and this is really important
crucially then hit that notification
bell so you actually get notified when
you want these videos drop a big thank
you goes out to our patrons over on
patreon for their amazing support I
especially want to thank our pro hero to
your patrons the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson and angel
Cruz and are the one tier patrons the
ones who stand atop all clans baby ray a
17 FTP Steven n grata a lowland autumn
Maddie Mac 239 makoto-kun and keelon and
lastly the one who transcends greatness
itself Regan Harrison the one who has
been acknowledged by Lords we go himself
if you like videos like this one and
they give you value please consider
going over to our patreon and donating
as little as a dollar a month it would
mean a lot if you do your name would be
featured among these legendary people
right here and you would get access to
our private patron only discord if
you're interested go to
patreon.com/scishow
in the description thanks again for all
your support and until next time see you
space Cowboys
[Music]